[Music]
top hats and bowler hats both originated
in england the top had emerged in the
late 1700s as a daring new style
radically higher than the flat three
cornered hat men wore at the time
then the bowler was invented around 1850
as a lower alternative to the top hat
today even women wear bowlers
top hats remain by and large a masculine
fashion statement reserved for formal
occasions although magicians are still
known to use them to produce rabbits
at the hat factory workers spray a fine
mist of water on hoods pre-cut hat forms
made of 100 wool felt
after the moisture penetrates overnight
they steam them for about two minutes
the moisture and heat deactivate a
chemical stiffener in the felt making
the material malleable then they place
the hood in an aluminum top hat mold
which applies heat and pressure
simultaneously
they place a string in a groove along
the perimeter and pull
this rolls back the edge of the felt to
form a rim then they trim off the excess
felt
after about 90 seconds of molding at
approximately 230 degrees fahrenheit
they remove the string and open her up
the top hat is now dry and fully shaped
however the felt is still malleable so
to reactivate the stiffener and lock in
the shape they set the head aside for
about 30 seconds to cool
to make a bowler hat the process up to
that point is identical but with a
bowler shaped mold
for both hat styles it takes two sets of
hands to pull the hood taut over the
bottom part of the mold to avoid
creating pleats or creases
there's a separate mold not just for
each hatch dial but for each size of
each style
after the bowler comes off the mold and
cools they give it a second more precise
trimming
both styles are finished the same way
first a seamstress takes a wide ribbon
folds it over the edge of the hat
and sews it down on both sides encasing
the edge
another seamstress uses a gold leaf
stamping machine to apply the
traditional british milliner's crest and
made in england to the hat's lining
the lining fabric is a silk satin blend
she sews the stamped top piece to the
side piece
the machine automatically pleats at
regular intervals so the lining will lie
flat against the hat's crown
[Music]
bowler hats are more rigid than top hats
so they require an extra application of
stiffener inside the crown
once the stiffener dries thoroughly
which takes the better part of the day
the hat is ready to receive its elegant
lining
they attach it with hot glue which dries
almost instantly
next they cut a strip of leather to the
hat size and sew the ends together with
a decorative zigzag stitch
the leather has been specially treated
to prevent mildew buildup resulting from
perspiration
they sew this leather band to the inside
of the hat at the base of the crown
covering the edge of the lining
not only does this produce a neat and
classy finish the leather band also
makes the hat more comfortable to wear
by cushioning the forehead
now it's time to finish the outside of
the hat
first they hot glue a cotton ribbon
around the base of the crown
next they glue on a matching bow
the grand finale is a small silk satin
bow on the interior leather band then
below that the manufacturer's label
a few taps with the sticky side of
adhesive tape easily removes lint dust
and wayward strands of hot glue
these elegant toppers and bowlers are
the product of several experienced
skilled craftspeople
hats off to them
[Music]
you